Gabriel "FalleN" Toledo is a two-time Major winner, a respected in-game leader and a devastating
AWPer. And, while his success on Counter-Strike's biggest stages alone would be enough to mark him as one of the best players in CS:GO
history, his legacy is built of so much more than in-game results.  This is his story.
FalleN was born on May 30th, 1991 and grew up near
Sao Paulo, Brazil. At a young age he gained a love of video games by watching over his brother's shoulder as he played.
He was a natural talent in Counter-Strike and by 14 he was already competing on his first team,
Crashers, in Brazilian CS 1.6
tournaments and World Cyber Games events.
A few years later he was asked to join Fire Gamers, whose roster included well-known talents Like Lincoln "fnx" Lau
and Renato "nak" Nakano.
FalleN's reputation quickly spread outside of Brazil thanks to impressive individual performances at ESWC and WCG events.
His deadly ability with the AWP marked him as the heir apparent to Raphael "cogu" Camargo
the best player in Brazil and star of MiBR.
Thorin: 'What happens is amazingly enough a player comes up
as a rising talent who basically was as close to cogu as you could ever get in play style,
skill set and even like the role that he used in the team it was like a cogu is cogu 2.0.'
However, just as FalleN was coming into his own as a legitimate star-level talent, Counter-Strike in Brazil began to wane.
Players became split between 1.6 and the newer Counter-Strike: Source
While at the same time the upper echelon
competitors of the scene, such as cogu himself, began to retire or move away from CS.
But, FalleN's passion for the game was unwavering
So, he began teaching online Counter-Strike classes, the profits of which he used to create Games Academy in January of
2012, a school dedicated to teaching
high-level Counter-Strike.
FalleN: 'The main idea of this project is to give you guys a good content on how you can become a better CS:GO player.
And we're gonna be talking about a lot of stuff, a lot of tips, a lot of strategies, a lot of thought you need to understand and
how you can improve your game.'
For the next few years
FalleN continued to grind away, a figurehead around which Brazilian Counter-Strike, rallied but growth was slow,
even after the release of Global Offensive in 2012.  However, once FalleN himself made the switch to CS:GO,
his career quickly regained momentum.
After a stint on Pro Gaming.TD,
FalleN became a founding member of KaBuM! eSports' CS:GO division. The roster, which reunited
FalleN with fnx, also included Fernando "fer" Alvarenga
and the young guns of Lucas "LUCAS1" Teles and Henrique "HEN1" Teles. The move would prove to be a
significant stepping stone in FalleN's career because it connected him with fer, who has since become his right-hand man.
Unfortunately for KaBuM!, their first big international event, ESWC 2014, did not go well.
Their flop, plus a merger between KaBuM! and Pro Gamers.TD,
prompted a roster shakeup leading Into FalleNs' next big test, the MLG Aspen Invitational.
Sadokist: 'Doesn't matter Zqk and steel still get it! It's over just like that! Cloud9 get obliterated
against the Brazilians, KaBuM! I don't think anyone saw that coming and Cloud9 looks stunned. They look speechless.
And watch out world - Brazil's got a contender. They look so so so good as a team right now.'
While they didn't make it out of groups, FalleN's preparation and tactics took center stage as KaBuM!TD
dismantled American favorites Cloud9 in an impressive map win.
The performance caught the attention of the community, putting FalleN back on the map.
KaBuM! followed that up with a solid quarterfinal finish at ClutchCon 2015. Their upward trajectory seemed set.
An invitation to the ESL One Katowice 2015 qualifiers was FalleN's reward.  But there was just one problem:
Money
KaBuM!TD couldn't afford to fly the team to Poland for the qualifier.  For a team on the rise,
missing the Major qualifier would be a disaster.
FalleN: 'It was fantastic because in five days we raise it all - the money we needed.'
While the community initially came through with around four thousand Euros, it was Fnatic's
Robin "flusha" Ronnquist who was the hero
Donating a 1400 Euro portion of his share of Fnatic's first-place winnings at The IOS Pantamara to the Brazilians.
After an additional twenty five hundred dollar donation by ESEA,
KaBuM!TD was able to make their way to Poland in time for the qualifier.
But, successfully qualifying would mean little if they didn't perform at The Major itself, even with a new sponsor, Keyd Stars
Taking the financial worries off the team's mind.
Thankfully, the Brazilians once again showed up in a big way.
[casting]
TaZ: 'It's jus the start for [Keyd Stars]. I know they were happy with the score already.
Like, with the quarterfinals. But, maybe next tear or next event we can see more of them'
Hiko: 'Still, well played to Keyd. Like, they had a great showing this tournament and I think they kind of proved everyone wrong.
That, you know, nobody else other than American and Europe can actually
play well in these events. They played really well and congratulations to them.'
The top 8 finish was enough to earn the team Legend status and a guaranteed spot in the next Major.
It was a massive weight off of FalleN's shoulders and the culmination of all he had worked for.
Brazil, which had been quiet since Mibr's decline was officially back on the radar.
While they had already come so far, it was clear that FalleN and his squad couldn't reach their full capabilities while based in Brazil.
And so, they signed with Luminosity Gaming and moved to California,
where they would be able to train with the best North America had to offer while also having more chances to compete in tournaments.
The decision was not easy, as it meant being away from his family for an extended period of time.
But, it was one that had to be made if FalleN was
to continue to lead his team to the top.
The move to North America also meant adding star player Marcelo "coldzera" David
to the mix, who, under FalleN's guidance, would blossom into one of the best players in the world.
[casting]
Another top eight finish at the next Major, ESL One Cologne,
just a month later not only
Proved that the result in Katowice wasn't just a fluke, but that the move to NA had been worth it.
However, he knew there were plenty of talented players back at home in Brazil, waiting for their opportunity to shine.
So, in August of 2015
He held a tournament called 'The Golden Chance'. The winning team he would personally
sponsor under The Game's Academy brand and move them to North America.
Not only would the new team be able to take full advantage of
The NA practice environment,
FalleN and Luminosity would have a new practice partner just as dedicated and passionate for the game as they were.
The winners were familiar faces:
fnx, Hen1 and Lucas1 along with young talents of Epitacio "TACO" de Melo and
Gustavo "SHOOWTIME" Goncalves. Only a few months into their time in NA,
Luminosity Gaming had improved dramatically. But, they were still bumping against the ceiling presented by European and CIS teams, especially
Fnatic and Natus Vincere. Once again, FalleN needed to take a close look at his team and make a hard choice.
On November 23rd, only a few days before the FACEIT Stage 3 Finals at DreamHack Winter 2015,
FalleN moved fnx and TACO from Games Academy into Luminosity to replace Boltz and steel.
In addition, Zews was brought in as a new coach in place of nak.
The move was sudden, and eyebrows were raised as the Brazilians headed into DreamHack with little practice to speak of.
They were completely slaughtered in Their first game.
[casting]
But, FalleN wasn't going to let a little
obstacle like an 0-16 beatdown a stop him and his team. In a now legendary performance
Luminosity surged back into the event, defeating Ninjas in Pyjamas...
[casting]
Team EnVyUs...
and Team SoloMid...
[casting]
...in dramatic best-of-threes to finish second at the event behind Fnatic.
Something had clicked with the new Luminosity. Wth FalleN and Zews' tactics, fer's consistency,
coldzera's superstar power and the dynamic talents of fnx and TACO, LG
finally had all the pieces they needed to take their game to the next level.
'If I was now Luminosity, all I would like recall from this tournament is a
crazy comeback. Being able to pick ourselves up even though getting beaten down on the first day one.
They played different maps against different teams,
had very very decent result. They just changed two players! I mean they should just look forward and just try to focus on their weaknesses.
But, this is just something to build on - obviously.'
After second place finishes at DreamHack Leipzig and the IEM World Championship in early 2016,
Luminosity continued to prove that they had what It took to make a play for the next Major title.
FalleN was the talk of the town:
not only was his tactical mind and inspiring leadership a clear
catalyst to LG's success, but he had returned to the level of play that had made him a star in 1.6.
His team played with smarts, skills and limitless passion, making them not only
incredibly entertaining to watch, but easy to root for.
Luminosity Gaming entered into the MLG Columbus Major in April of 2016 hungry for a title.
[casting]
Anders: 'And it's Luminosity winning their first Major championship!'
It was one of the most dramatic runs in Major history. FalleN had finally done it: more than ten years after his first
Counter-Strike tournament, he had a restored Brazil to a position of power and glory in the world.
It was indisputable that LG was the best team in the world, with FalleN their mastermind, their leader.
Redeye: 'Can you sum up to me just what this means to the country of Brazil and your teammates?'
FalleN: 'Just to sum it up this is our dream coming true and winning the biggest tournament ever on CS:GO
means so much to me personally, and I'm sure it means a kot to my teammates as well.'
However, their success had not gone unnoticed
and with that came complications.
The team became embroiled in a controversial scandal surrounding their sponsor and a potential switch to SK Gaming.
Despite signing a Letter of Intent to re-sign with Luminosity Gaming,
the team had signed contracts With SK Gaming and just prior to MLG Columbus.
The result was a lengthy public debate and a legal battle over the future of the team, which was eventually
settled on June 24th, 2016, when the team officially transferred to SK.
Their first tournament under the SK banner was the ESL One Cologne Major.
And just as they had at MLG, the Brazilians were gunning to take it all.
FalleN: 'Our path to get here was very difficult, we had to go through a lot of things.
So, when we have a chance to win another title we're gonna do everything we can to win it. So we're feeling blessed
to be here and we wanna make a great show and do our best.'
They didn't falter in their mission.
[casting]
Anders: 'And SK Gaming - second Major championship in a row! They are your winners!'
Back-to-back Major titles left absolutely no doubt: not only was the roster one of the greatest to ever play CS:GO,
FalleN was one of the greatest in-game leaders of the modern era.
FalleN: 'Yeah, I think we found the perfect team. We have been trying for so long.
I personally have been trying since 2009.
Seven years trying to achieve tournaments and I have the perfect guys on my side.
I mean everyone - all of them played so well.'
Heading into the back half of 2016, everyone expected FalleN and SK
to continue to take home the hardware. But, behind the scenes trouble was brewing.
Fnx, always known as a bad boy,
was causing tension in the team. While SK's results were nothing to sneeze at,
they were not were FalleN hoped they would be. He had fought so hard to reach the top and
anything less than first was a disappointment now that he had tasted victory.
Fnx was removed from the team and SK Gaming played the ELEAGUE Major in January of 2017 with Ricardo "fox" Pachero
as a stand-in while the team sought out a new fifth member.
Proving just how good the team was, even with a stand-in SK Gaming still finished top four at the event.
Eventually, the up-and-coming star of Immortals, Joao "felps" Vasconcellos
was selected to join the SK ranks. The team was once again focused, driven and determined to win titles.
The rest, as they say, is history.
[casting]
FalleN's story is one of hard work paying off,
dedication reaping rewards and passion leading to victory.
His nickname of 'The Godfather of Brazilian CS' is more than just a moniker - he's earned it.
Games Academy, which started as just an online class all those years ago,  now boasts its own content creators and has witnessed its
former roster, now sponsored by Immortals, finish second at the recent PGL Major.
FalleN was once named "The Most Influential Person in Brazilian Esports" in 2015 for his work building the community,
teaching and spreading the word of esports.
He's a two-time Major winner,
a respected leader, a fierce competitor. In every aspect of his life
FalleN has gone above and beyond - and something tells us he's just getting started.
Thanks for Watching if You want more Great content be sure to hit that subscribe button